[Música]
el 3 de mayo es conmemorado el Día
Mundial de la libertad de prensa esta
fecha cumple justamente 30 años de haber
sido proclamada por la Organización de
las Naciones Unidas con la que buscan
generar una fuerza digamos impulsora de
los Derechos Humanos a través de la
libertad de expresión como es habitual
en este tipo de fechas pues es el
momento para hacer un balance de la
situación sobre todo en nuestra región
en América Latina y ver con detalle la
labor periodística en los diferentes
países los avances las amenazas a la
seguridad de los periodistas tanto en
naciones democráticas como en esas
naciones que tienen gobiernos
considerados autocráticos para destacar
pues varios temas por ejemplo el manejo
que le han dado varios gobiernos a la
relación con la prensa una relación que
ya de por sí es difícil pero sobre este
tema se refirió justamente guillem
canela de Sousa Godoy el jefe de la
sección de libertad de expresión y
seguridad de los periodistas
escuchemos sus palabras
en los últimos años Estamos monitoreando
un mayor número de líderes políticos
pero también líderes religiosos y
celebridades que han desarrollado una
narrativa contra el periodismo han usado
expresiones como o el periodismo es una
noticia falsa o todo el periodismo es
corrupto o todo el periodismo no es
verdadero
y cuando hicimos nuestra investigación
sobre los ataques a periodistas que
cubrían protestas Aparentemente hay una
conexión entre estos llamados contra el
periodismo y la violencia Real contra
los periodistas
entonces lo que hemos estado
monitoreando es un intento creciente de
socavar El periodismo como institución
central para proteger a los
comunicadores los derechos humanos y las
democracias
nuestra región América Latina enfrenta
enormes desafíos son muchos los riesgos
y amenazas a los que se están
enfrentando a los periodistas para poder
cubrir tanto terreno como para
simplemente poder entregar información
hemos sido testigos de ataques
cibernéticos de cierres de medios de
comunicación asesinatos de periodistas
persecución censura poco acceso a las
fuentes de información también el exilio
Y por supuesto las amenazas casos como
el de Nicaragua con varios periodistas
en el exilio el de El Salvador que está
bajo un estado de excepción en donde las
garantías constitucionales están
suspendidas Pues no hay garantías para
ejercer el periodismo allí al 100% como
debería de ser o también por ejemplo la
persecución en Guatemala o las altas
cifras de asesinatos de periodistas en
México una mezcla de todos los aspectos
los podemos ver en Colombia en donde hay
asesinatos persecución periodistas
exiliados difícil acceso a la
información en algunos casos Allí se
mezclan prácticamente diferentes o todos
los aspectos pero en Venezuela por
ejemplo los medios tradicionales
desaparecieron con el paso de los años y
quienes quedan en el exilio claman por
el respeto los derechos humanos en este
país suramericano como ven el tema pues
es largo tiene múltiples aristas y por
eso pues mejor Comencemos hoy en el
debate de France 24 la situación de la
libertad de prensa en América Latina y
también en el mundo para analizar este
tema como hemos invitado a Carlos
journet Él es presidente de la comisión
de libertad de prensa e información de
la sociedad Interamericana de prensa se
encuentra en la ciudad de Córdoba en
Argentina y aquí en el estudio de France
24 me acompaña Fabiola León ella es
representante de reporteros Sin
fronteras en la ciudad de Bogotá en
Colombia los dos les doy la bienvenida a
nuestro programa ustedes nuestros
televidentes ya lo saben hacen parte de
esta discusión pueden dejar preguntas
comentarios dudas a través de los
diferentes canales que tenemos
habilitados en las redes sociales nos
encuentran en Twitter en Facebook en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 todo junto y a mí me me
encuentran en Twitter como arroba
santilogos en mi cuenta personal no
olviden también que todos los contenidos
del programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces con nuestro invitado
en la ciudad de Córdoba en Argentina
Carlos Bienvenido al programa Gracias
por acompañarnos el día de hoy y retomo
algunas de las reflexiones que hay en
este informe presentado este 3 de mayo
que dice que y lo pongo a consideración
cree usted que el periodismo está
simplemente atravesando como una especie
de crisis un momento complicado un
momento de transición en el que también
la tecnología ha empezado a absorber un
gran campo o verdaderamente el
periodismo y los medios de comunicación
están bajo amenaza en nuestro planeta
Es evidente que el periodismo está bajo
amenaza en el planeta pero
específicamente en la región en América
Latina como bien decías en la
introducción el panorama es
extremadamente complejo por esa mezcla
de asedio censura y muerte que señalaba
recién en el videograph
hay muchos periodistas que han tenido
que emigrar
países enteros como Nicaragua y
Venezuela donde prácticamente ya no
queda periodismo independiente Pero eso
se conjuga también con los cambios
tecnológicos los cambios sociales y
también el impacto económico que eso
tiene sobre la industria de los medios
sobre la industria periodística entonces
hay que trabajar sobre ambos aspectos en
paralelo no decir por un lado trabajar
contra la intolerancia contra los
gobiernos autocráticos contra aquellos
que quieren imponer la censura pero
también garantizar un nuevo entorno que
la sostenibilidad de los medios y del
periodismo independiente para poder
consolidar ese
escenario de de información libre que
permita El Avance de la sociedad no Y
para cerrar esta primera ronda Fabiola
que en él estudió Francis veinticuatro
bienvenida un gusto tenerla con nosotros
hoy en el programa y la misma pregunta
como Punto de partida es una
redefinición del del rol que tienen los
medios de comunicación o claramente aquí
estamos viendo una amenaza al ejercicio
periodístico y a los medios en sí Bueno
yo creo que en general lo que tenemos es
una crisis que viene de hace mucho
tiempo lo que pasa es que cada vez
tenemos un enfoque o una variable que
viene perjudicando aún más el tema de el
ejercicio profesional Entonces si vienen
algún momento estaba por ejemplo la
crisis de los grandes medios de
comunicación por su financiación en este
momento estamos viendo una gran crisis
de la credibilidad de los medios de
comunicación a nivel mundial y eso pasa
por
como la Inteligencia artificial o por
esta cantidad de Boom o cambios que se
dan en el en el ecosistema Pero quiero
dejar algo claro y es que no solamente
el tema de libertad de expresión se
puede ver por la violencia directa que
podemos hablar cuando decimos amenazas
homicidios sino que hay que mirarlo
integralmente entonces hay que ver
variables económicas políticas sociales
que entran a jugar y no solamente por el
número de casos que podamos sumar claro
importantes aclaración una Arista más
para analizar aquí en el programa La
dejo sobre la mesa me parece interesante
continuó con usted Fabiola viendo este
informe y lo mencionaba yo en la
introducción mencioné algunos países de
Centroamérica Carlos hablaba del caso de
Nicaragua por ejemplo
hay dos países muy particulares que
quiero entender Qué es lo que está
llevando a estos países por ese rumbo y
es Cuba entendemos el tipo de gobierno
que tiene este país y Honduras son los
países que están en la peor
clasificación en la región de América
Latina están prácticamente entre las
últimas 15 posiciones del Gran listado a
nivel internacional incluso por debajo
de países como por ejemplo Nicaragua
donde hay tantas tanta preocupación por
la libertad de expresión o donde hay
tanta preocupación por ejemplo en El
Salvador por ese estado de excepción
Cuba podemos tener un poco más indicios
de que lo que sucede pero Honduras
sorprenden este listado en la región de
Centroamérica Fabiola que que se está
conjugando allí bueno eso tiene que ver
efectivamente con el problema en la
inestabilidad política que se ha venido
generando entonces hay presiones de lado
político y el ambiente para volver a
estas categorías el ambiente social que
se está dando Entonces tenemos el
ambiente político el ambiente social y a
eso le Podemos agregar efectivamente
como algunas presiones o intimidaciones
que vienen siendo ya más de tipo de
seguridad Entonces tenemos tres factores
que entran a conjugar aquí y por lo cual
estamos viendo un panorama más difícil
del ejercicio de la libertad de
expresión Entonces no hay las garan
tampoco hay garantías jurídicas digamos
que esto también se vino desdibujando en
estos países entonces a pesar de que la
ley diga algunas cosas No necesariamente
se están llevando a cabo y por eso
encontramos un panorama muy difícil para
estos países a mí me llamó mucho la
atención Encontrarme a Honduras en esos
en esos últimos lugares por eso lo traje
para la mesa del debate Carlos Cuál es
su percepción sobre estos dos casos en
particular
Sí nosotros desde la sociedad
Interamericana de prensa elaboramos
anualmente un índice del índice
Chapultepec y nosotros tenemos ubicado
allí a tres países de la región que son
Nicaragua Venezuela y Cuba Honduras
Obviamente que ha tenido una degradación
importante pero creemos que hay países
donde directamente no existe libertad de
expresión ni libertad de prensa y la
prueba está lo que ha ocurrido en las
últimas elecciones o los últimos
procesos electorales tanto en Venezuela
como Nicaragua que fueron procesos
amañados donde se ha perseguido la
disidencia se ha encarcelado a los
opositores el gobierno de Nicaragua
acaba de expulsar a 222
precios políticos varios de ellos
periodistas se les ha quitado la
nacionalidad se les han quitado los los
derechos las garantías las propiedades
decírselos ha condenado a la muerte
civil Entonces
sí claramente Honduras es un país que
está viviendo un proceso de degradación
como lo vi de Guatemala como lo está
viviendo Perú Ecuador pero creemos que
las situaciones más críticas en la
región siguen siendo la de los tres
países que le acabo de mencionar Cuba
Nicaragua y Venezuela sintiendo algunas
críticas la situación de estos estados
Fabiola llamada la atención en este
informe que ningún país del continente
americano está en la categoría verde que
es se considera que es la categoría
Bueno o sea que hay una libre
la libertad de expresión Pues están los
niveles más altos estos listados los
encabezan los países nórdicos que
también han tenido algunas algunos
descensos como por ejemplo el de
Finlandia pero pero brillan siempre en
esta en esta lista Suecia Noruega los
Países Bajos Dinamarca y Finlandia en
este caso América no está presente
Pero uno mira y pues uno no pensaría
bueno y Canadá porque no está presente
ese es un país con una amplia democracia
Un estado social bien sustentado estos
países porque no están haciendo
presencia allí o por ejemplo Estados
Unidos yo creo que hay que mirar un poco
también como explicar un poco la manera
como se construyen estos indicadores Sí
primero lo hacemos estamos hablando de
el año pasado Digamos como para ilustrar
un poco dos se hace como con la
interpretación de muchos actores no
solamente periodistas sino también
académicos o Defensores de Derechos
Humanos Pero además tiene que ver como
con las coyunturas que que ocurrieron
entonces a veces un país baja y otro
sube o a veces si está muy mal la
situación a nivel mundial Pues todos
vamos a estar muy mal Entonces digamos
que eso hace que se modifiquen las
circunstancias Estados Unidos si bien Se
supone que es como el uno en América es
uno de los países que podría ser ejemplo
pues no lo encontramos en una muy buena
posición de a pesar de los esfuerzos que
ha dado biden de todas maneras tenemos
problemas de violencia y tenemos dos
asesinatos que se dan en Estados Unidos
pero en general en todo el continente a
veces uno tiende a pensar que los países
que tienen un régimen dictatorial van a
ser los peores países y lo que hemos
encontrado es que hay muchas democracias
que igual tienen problemas de libertad
de expresión porque es que además han
cambiado muchas cosas como el ecosistema
de medios entonces todo este auge del
internet también hace que se modifiquen
esa realidades entonces Estados Unidos
antes no aparecía en los últimos años
para acá ha venido apareciendo en una
situación más problemática que la que
presentábamos antes en general el
continente tiene algunos países que
estaban bien Pero veamos un ejemplo
veamos Perú como para poder comparar
ahorita se mencionaban tres países que
están gravemente en frente a la región
uno decía pero no aparecía ahora aparece
Por qué Porque hay un cambio hay una
estabilidad inestabilidad política que
se presenta con los presidentes Y eso
generó obviamente un estallido social y
genera un ambiente bastante hostil para
la prensa entonces pero no había
aparecido ahora apareció vemos casos
como Chile Chile normalmente no aparece
en las mediciones y uno diría que tiene
una buena
una buena situación de libertad de
prensa sin embargo hay un ambiente
enrarecido precisamente frente al cambio
de gobierno entonces hay como una
amenaza o se siente una amenaza frente
al ejercicio de los grandes medios de
comunicación ahí son variables de Por
qué no aparecen unos y porque si
aparecen otros claro hay una diferencia
Hay ciertos países europeos que ganan
una estabilidad en el tiempo que no lo
hemos logrado tanto así en la
estabilidad en múltiples factores no
solamente políticas sino que también hay
una estabilidad económica que también le
da un sustento de largo aliento en los
medios de comunicación es que ese es un
punto importante la forma en que estamos
laborando los periodistas también va a
cambiar la dinámica de libertad de
expresión Entonces como usted bien lo
acaba de decir si no tenemos unas
garantías económicas va a ser más
difícil que existan perfectas
condiciones para poder hacer un
ejercicio periodístico más responsable
claro Carlos su opinión sobre este tema
este panorama general del continente
ninguno en verde pero podemos mejorar
que empezar a hacer para mejorar
estabilidad política estabilidad
económica la mayoría de países están
tratando de salir adelante a recuperar
los puntos económicos después de la
pandemia de Kobe 19 y de la Guerra de
Ucrania Que todavía nos sigue dando
coletazos a todos
sí sin duda que la situación económica
de la región
realmente afecta el ejercicio del
periodismo y sobre todo de un periodismo
de investigación un periodismo que
profundice en los hechos sociales y que
ayuda a la ciudadanía al debate público
como bien decía Fabiola los índices
muchas veces comparan situaciones de un
año para otro teniendo en cuenta la
realidad de un país en México por
ejemplo los últimos seis meses no hay
ningún asesinato eso no quiere decir que
México esté mejor que otros países donde
pudo haber un asesinato en los meses
recientes sino que simplemente
se dan determinadas condiciones que
comparativamente lo ayudan a mejorar
entonces claramente la realidad
económica del periodismo hoy es un tema
extremadamente complejo porque hay una
competencia muy fuerte de parte de las
redes sociales los líderes políticos
descargan sus dardos contra la prensa
también porque saben que tienen otras
vías para llegar a la ciudadanía con sus
mensajes aunque éstas no siempre sean
creíbles pero todo eso Configura un un
cuadro que debe ser abordado en forma
integral para garantizar un ejercicio
periodístico que ayude a la
consolidación democrática en toda la
región importante ese punto Carlos y eso
me lleva a preguntarle a un punto que
estábamos destacando en la introducción
del programa y es esa relación entre los
liderazgos de los diferentes gobiernos
en los diferentes países que pensaría
uno se sienten amenazados o se sienten
en cierta forma desacreditados o
intimidados y por eso
estos diferentes casos que vemos
Comenzando por Estados Unidos en donde
hay señalamientos por parte del gobierno
directo a los medios de comunicación
para desacreditarlos para derrumbar ese
ejercicio periodístico acusarlos de
noticias falsas o de no estar
cercanos a la verdad de los hechos que
están difundiendo Cómo entender esa esa
relación o esa crisis que se está
presentando entre los liderazgos y los
medios de comunicación esto es nuevo
ahora que lo vimos por ejemplo con el
presidente Donald Trump o con el caso de
bolsonaro en Brasil o como en otros
casos en en Venezuela en su momento
cuando estaba Chávez
o esto es una relación que siempre ha
sido difícil
no es una relación que se ha ido
acentuando en los últimos años creo que
el ejemplo de Trump que no es novedoso
porque de algún modo tomó un discurso
que venía practicando desde hace unos
años Hugo Chávez por ejemplo en
Venezuela y puede parecer paradójico
pero es así Hugo Chávez el Rafael Correa
Néstor kirchner en Argentina
luego Trump bolsonaro
Andrés Manuel López Obrador en México
buscan a la prensa como enemigo por un
lado para descalificarla y de ese modo
cualquier crítica que la prensa le haga
su gestión ya pierde sustento porque él
previamente el presidente previamente la
descalificó Pero además va ayudando a
construir una crítica social al
ejercicio de la prensa que después se
puede traducir en hechos de violencia
como bien decías también en la
introducción de este de este programa
realmente es una situación que se va
retroalimentando y donde los hechos de
violencia empiezan a producirse en
protestas callejeras por ejemplo donde
la prensa ve a un periodista ejerciendo
su trabajo de reportear pero ve también
a un enemigo que puede llevar a
una confrontación política Entonces se
producen hechos de violencia que
terminan en muchos casos con la muerte
de periodista no en Estados Unidos por
ejemplo hubo un periodista muerto en una
manifestación en Chile hubo periodista
también murió víctima de una
manifestación callejera entonces
adelante Bueno creo que hay que mirar
varias cosas como bien dice Carlos pues
es un tema que viene ya de tiempo atrás
pero
obedece o digamos que también hay que
entenderlo tratar de explicarlo América
Latina se considera que es uno de los
continentes que tiene mayor
concentración de medios en términos de
propiedad y de audiencia entonces
estábamos muy acostumbrados
efectivamente hay que la cercanía del
poder político con los medios de
comunicación había eso había una
cercanía esto se empieza a romper se
nota mucho cuando llega la época
efectivamente de Chávez Correa Álvaro
Uribe esto se empieza a a ver que está
cambiando se está modificando no es que
haya cambiado la propiedad de los medios
en este momento No necesariamente no hay
un cambio grande pero sí ha cambiado la
manera como se como se está como fluye
La información entonces se está
agudizando también porque han cambiado
el tipo de gobernante entonces son
varias cosas que nos llevan a ver que
efectivamente la atención
va en aumento entre un poder y el otro
ahora Bien también hay que entender que
los medios de comunicación normalmente
hemos manejado un discurso de el control
del poder político Entonces es como si
nos hubiéramos casado con una pelea que
va a ser por toda la vida y la vemos
como una pelea entonces creo que a veces
también nos hace falta
ver el debate o ver la confrontación a
la discusión en buenos términos y no
como peleas entonces creo que es algo en
lo que no hemos logrado atravesar en
generar los países
el el periodismo puede ejercer su
control político efectivamente pero no
necesariamente tiene que estar en una
enfrentamiento entonces hemos
considerado una pelea algo que realmente
puede ser una discusión normal de dos
posturas o de dos ambientes entonces
creo que debemos caminar un poco más
hacia la posibilidad de discutir sin
necesidad de que piensen igual que que
yo o sea me refiero Hay que llegar a
consensos sobre cosas comunes aunque
seamos diferentes claro eso eso pero
bueno eso es un escenario complicado
para América Latina donde los choques
son frecuentes eso me lleva a
preguntarle sobre la concentración de
los medios en los diferentes países de
América Latina en muy pocas manos en muy
pocas manos de económicos en muy pocos
sí grandes fortunas de estos países
latinoamericanos que es lo normal y un
escenario parecido también ha tenido
lugar en la India que ha bajado unos
cuantas posiciones en el ranking a nivel
internacional porque la gran mayoría de
los medios de comunicación pasaron a
estar en manos de grandes fortunas que
son cercanas al gobierno actual y allí
También hay un detrimento
informativo América Latina necesita para
garantizar Entonces esta buena
información este flujo de información
expandir el espectro agrandar porque
sigue muy concentrados yo creo que no es
solamente agrandar o sea digamos y no es
acabar que a veces se interpreta que
cuando hacemos este tipo de
observaciones es atacando a los grandes
medios o a las empresas creo que todos
tenemos la posibilidad de existir lo que
pasa es que los que son más pequeños
necesitan mayor soporte entonces
en la gran falencia que han tenido en
general en América los medios
los medios comunitarios alternativos es
un problema de sostenibilidad financiera
Entonces si logramos
sostenerlos mejor podemos garantizar una
diversidad ahora a veces entendemos que
lo diverso y lo plural es porque hayan
muchos y No necesariamente es que hayan
muchos lo que pasa es que yo creo que
podemos ser supremamente amplios y
tenemos que tener es la posibilidad de
que se presenten posturas diferentes no
es muchos hablando de lo mismo es muchos
hablando de cosas diferentes desde
puntos de vista diferentes entonces
necesitamos mejorar el ecosistema en los
más chiquitos para que podamos coexistir
todo pluralidad informativa de cada
quien su informe por el lado que que le
guste
enfocar el la información hay un tema
importante acá y es el tipo de
dificultades que uno ve comparando
América Latina con otras regiones de
América Latina el escenario que tenemos
Nosotros con otras regiones el escenario
que tenemos nosotros es sumamente
violento y agresivo con la prensa la
cantidad de muertos que tiene lugar
anualmente en México las amenazas las
investigaciones que quedan inconclusas
porque las personas que las están
adelantando
son Víctimas de la persecución y y de
diferentes hechos de violencia esto Cómo
se puede empezar a cambiar esto lo hemos
hablado Este programa creo que lo he
hecho unas cuatro veces acá en France 24
y siempre llegamos a esta misma pregunta
y yo no veo cambios en los últimos años
no veo un un nuevo cambio un nuevo
camino que lleve a mejorar las
condiciones y a reducir la violencia
hacia hacia la prensa siempre somos
vistos en gran forma como una amenaza
para grupos económicos para políticos
Carlos su opinión
Sí en la región Está avanzando muy
lentamente la adopción de modelos de
protección a periodistas sobre todo en
situaciones críticas en situaciones
donde hay un crimen organizado países
con fuerte presencia del narcotráfico
por ejemplo México bueno Colombia
en los años pasados
Brasil la misma Argentina hoy está
debatiendo este tema Paraguay
sin embargo no se terminan de aplicar o
algunos de esos protocolos de protección
a periodistas luego no se le asignan los
recursos suficientes como para que
puedan ser herramientas eficaces para
que el periodismo pueda seguir
ejerciendo su profesión sin tener la
muerte o permanentemente
ataques y robo de de herramientas de
elementos de trabajo entonces creo que
hay que seguir trabajando en esos
mecanismos y también que los propios
medios de comunicación aportemos
nuestros reporteros a nuestros
periodistas de las herramientas y de la
capacitación adecuada para trabajar en
situaciones decreciente violencia como
la que se vive en el Continente Fabiola
entonces hay una precarización de la de
la función periodística del oficio
periodístico y Por ende de la calidad
informativa que estamos teniendo en
América Latina yo creo que sí debemos
mejorar O sea creo que los periodistas
tenemos que hacer una una mirada
introspectiva para ver en qué deberíamos
mejorar
Y tratar efectivamente que la profesión
esté también en un nivel nuevamente
volver a decir por qué un periodista es
diferente a todos los ciudadanos que
puedan informar en eso creo que tenemos
que hacer un ejercicio juicioso creo que
para mejorar Habría que ver como cada
uno de estas dimensiones de las que
estamos hablando ahorita que Carlos
hablaba del tema de la protección
precisamente reporteros hizo un un
estudio para poder comparar esos
programas de protección y creo que en
eso hay que trabajar mucho más Solamente
un detalle caso colombiano es uno de los
programas que tiene más dinero para
poder proteger en general no solamente a
periodistas sino a las 17 poblaciones
Pero la gran conclusión de esto es que
falta una mirada de la protección de una
manera más integral y no solamente como
un tema de chalecos y carros blindados
propiamente sino la salud mental de los
periodistas eso es algo que está
bastante es se vulnera y no tiene la
atención que debería tener no solamente
los periodistas que estén en una
situación de riesgo sino la cantidad de
eventos Que terminamos
cubriendo Y eso genera unos problemas en
términos de Salud Mental dos creo que sí
hay que mejorar las condiciones
laborales en las que estamos porque
tenemos una demanda muy grande hacemos
muchas cosas o hacemos tres cosas en fin
para podernos dedicar como a una sola
cosa entonces hay que mejorar en
términos laborales pero también Creo que
hay que hacer un ejercicio con
ciudadanía y con otros como con otros
sectores frente a la importancia de lo
que hacemos Es que somos de las
profesiones que trabaja con un derecho
que es de todos el derecho a la
información es un derecho humano y a
veces no se entiende Desde esa manera se
entiende Como una profesión más y punto
no es tan sencillo Porque estamos
jugando con algo y no solamente la
patica de la Democracia no estamos
jugando con mucho más que una patica de
la Democracia entonces creo que hay que
hacer un un esfuerzo con la ciudadanía y
de nosotros como periodistas de las
empresas periodísticas y también de los
gobiernos como para poder
[Música]
abarcar todo lo que hay que mirar o sea
no es tan sencillo como
muy larga me salgo un poco de la región
de América Latina paso algo de los temas
internacionales porque en el momento que
estamos haciendo esto estamos en un
contexto de guerra y de confrontación y
el caso en particular de estos dos
países pues da para mucho mucho debatir
y es justamente ese manejo de la
propaganda por parte de Rusia y de
Ucrania en este conflicto también de
este lado del mundo también obviamente
ha habido todo tipo de oferta
propagandística
haciendo pues alusión a la actividad de
los países de este lado del mundo que
están involucrados en este conflicto no
voy a rescatar a ninguno de los dos
solamente pongo sobre la mesa pero qué
enseñanzas deja a nivel informativo el
ejercicio periodístico en esta Guerra de
Ucrania contra una maquinaria
periodística y promotora como es la rusa
que está en terreno pero también Ucrania
ha hecho lo propio estando allí en la
zona de conflicto Carlos
Bueno es muy difícil en situaciones de
conflicto llegar a la verdad
Real de lo que está ocurriendo pero en
el caso puntual de lo que está
ocurriendo en Ucrania con la invasión
rusa evidentemente
hay una un intento muy claro de los
grupos contendientes de impedir libre
ejercicio de la profesión sobre todo del
lado ruso hay una un silenciamiento de
la información hacia su propia población
que realmente
lleva a situaciones como las que ha
ocurrido recientemente de la detención
de un periodista
norteamericano que estaba ejerciendo su
profesión en Rusia y eso ha sido un
motivo de preocupación Pero además el
todo el tema de la desinformación del
manejo de la información por parte de
los países en conflicto y y el la
posibilidad de que la Inteligencia
artificial se para generar más
desinformación es el gran desafío que
enfrentamos hoy los periodistas en un
mundo donde el la posibilidad de conocer
Cuál es la verdad empieza a hacerse cada
vez más difusa porque empiezan a
aparecer fotografías videos audios claro
distorsionan totalmente la realidad no
Claro Carlos tenía para el cierre el
tema de la Inteligencia artificial ya lo
puso usted sobre la mesa Quiero conocer
la opinión que tiene Fabiola sobre este
tema de la guerra informática a nivel
internacional la situación de los
periodistas en terreno Y también esta
Alianza china Rusia que son países que
en este ranking no les va nada bien
conocemos como es la situación en estos
dos países el cierre de medios en Rusia
la cantidad de periodistas que ha
exiliados la censura que se maneja en
China y que no hay acceso a algunos
medios internacionales
que análisis se puede hacer de la
situación de estos dos países y ese
miedo que haya una alianza entre ellos
dos un engranaje internacional a nivel
informativo yo creo que en estos casos
digamos hay que mirar también
si bien hay una censura y un
silenciamiento interno resulta que
también hay un silenciamiento externo
Entonces como decía Rose es más difícil
cada vez poder ver o saber qué es lo que
está pasando y cuál es la realidad
Porque no solamente al interior se
silencian sino que por fuera también hay
silenciamientos entonces en muchos de
esos casos terminan los periodistas
hay si es cierto como los perjudicados
Dentro de este dentro de esta
confrontación política y el periodista
es el perjudicado en esto por qué hay
muchos corresponsales de estos dos
países que estaban en otros países y
fueron silenciados no solamente por su
país sino por los países donde estaban
entonces ahí queda uno como qué hacemos
para saber si no los dejamos Tampoco
hablar digamos que en estas alianzas
políticas que hacemos o por empatías
terminamos diciendo nada de lo que venga
de China lo vamos a acá Entonces por
decir un ejemplo en este canal no lo
vamos a pronunciar ahí entramos
nuevamente en un debate que ha sido
histórico de éticamente qué podemos
sacar y que no Aunque no estemos de
acuerdo con ese régimen o a que no
estemos de acuerdo con eso que está
pasando pero es más llamativo
efectivamente el tema de la propaganda y
la manera como se ha manejado la
propaganda En estos casos que en últimas
en la gran conclusión es la manera como
se seduce o se intenta seducir para
decir que tengo la razón eso es más
preocupante de lo que está de lo que
está pasando allá efectivamente estos
son los tres países que nos tienen como
con la alerta en rojo de allá no es
posible saber qué está pasando con la
información no son solamente las vidas y
aún así hay que decir que todo su
panorama no es el más catastrófico si
los miramos en términos de la
clasificación Aunque tienen unas
condiciones muy graves no están tan
lejos de algunos países americanos claro
entonces simplemente en una guerra
expresa que nos hace prestarle mayor
atención o sea tienen más ruido y por
eso Los vemos pero no necesariamente
estamos lejos de ellos como para decir
que eso pasa allá cuando tienes un
conflicto directo no pasa acá aunque no
tengamos un conflicto tan grande claro
Hay países latinoamericanos en el
ranking mucho más abajo que estos países
y Bueno creo que entiendo lo de la lo de
la censura externa digámoslo Así cuando
sacaron a los canales rusos de emisión
en diferentes países de Europa y pues la
gente ya no se puede informar por medio
de canales rusos sobre la guerra en
Ucrania pues véalo uno como lo quiera
ver pero pues no hay un acceso a la
información directamente desde Rusia
desde el lado occidente y si no lo miran
No en el canal sino en el periodista que
tiene dificultades para ganarse pues su
sueldo porque no tiene a quien informar
ahí empezamos hay que avanzar los
niveles para que la cadena de dominó Es
que a veces miramos como si fueran como
si no fueran personas y son personas las
que estamos haciendo periodismo somos
personas las que nos vemos frente a ese
tipo de problemáticas claro usted no era
solamente los canales rusos sino los
periodistas que estaban en los países
bueno esa reflexión para el cierre para
para terminar Me quedan pocos minutos
mencionó el tema de la Inteligencia
artificial creo que todos estamos
preocupados cómo vamos a abordar esto
hagamos la ronda la inversa Fabiola
percepciones sobre este tema su análisis
Claro Mira por ejemplo el caso de
Juliana Sánchez con esta pieza que se
creó
mostrándolo a él en un estado vegetativo
y esto se volvió viral digamos que él ha
sido una de las causas que para el caso
reporteros Sin fronteras ha sido
importante Mostrar su situación y
Mostrar lo que puede pasar frente a
porque ese silencian este tipo de hechos
como los que él estaba investigando
mostrando trabajando Entonces ahí uno
dice cómo vamos a hacer para que la
gente sepa que es verdad o no Qué tan
eso no antes la gente se podía poner
como si lo decía Frank 24 era cierto en
este momento ya no sabemos si también
podemos creerle a los grandes medios Esa
es la crisis la credibilidad la
credibilidad Carlos su reflexión sobre
el tema de la Inteligencia artificial
para el cierre adelante
Sí yo creo que no hay que negar o
rehusarse
a mirarlo posibles beneficios de la
Inteligencia artificial que creo que son
muchos si se lo utiliza bien como todo
tecnología pero evidentemente que hay
riesgos muy altos sobre todo de
plataformas que puedan ser desarrollados
por grandes por corporaciones o por
gobiernos autoritarios y que comiencen a
generar un relato pero con la ayuda
tecnológica para llegar a una masa
enorme de gente el otro día hice una
prueba de preguntarle a uno de los chats
que están muy de moda Cuáles son los
principales beneficios de la libertad de
expresión democracia y me dijo Bueno la
frase que todos conocemos sobre el valor
que tiene la libre expresión para la
construcción de ciudadanía etcétera
etcétera Pero luego le pedí que hiciera
el mismo discurso pero con la óptica
autoritaria y me dijo que había que
controlar el periodismo que el
periodismo era el enemigo del pueblo
bueno todo lo que sabemos también que
son los discursos habituales de los
autócratas latinoamericanos Entonces
evidentemente el mal uso de la
tecnología o la distorsión de la
tecnología puede llevar a riesgos
importantes además de los que decía
Fabiola sí de distorsión de la realidad
No apenas estamos viendo la punta del
iceberg de lo que puede significar la
Inteligencia artificial en este oficio
de informar y en la libertad de
expresión a Carlos y a Fabiola les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
tema con muchas aristas para analizar
Tratamos de darle una mirada rápida a la
región y entender cómo estamos les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
a ustedes también Muchas gracias por la
sintonía y la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Andrés doncel y
Johanna galvis y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera Pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]